welcome
the direct path number nine
piercing the veil in the dream
again
check out the other direct path videos
on our channel
notice how we are sharing
all of these different faces
paths
pit stops to the one
end
and you get to draw
from those which ones most resonate with
you and implement them
in your self slash god realization
and furthermore in your
realization
of even that as
an illusion slash dream
which we will unpack here in direct path
number nine
so intention pierce the veil in the
dream
so the
oceanic analogy has been extremely
profound throughout my journey and many
others so we'll go ahead and play with
it here
the most common way to understand the
quote
individual
that melts into the ocean
is the drop
that becomes the ocean
so when you hear people on their
spiritual journeys
when they are again would like to make a
preface
with the non-dual understanding that
there is no lack
everything's already perfect there's
nothing to seek the diamond
necklace is already around your neck it
just remains for you to recognize it
and that there is no lack it's all
absolutely perfect
there's no seeking to be done there's no
finding to be done
yet again in a perspective of true
simultaneity we recognize that there is
egoic
consciousness and that a goat
consciousness is currently seeking
externally for happiness
which it's hitting a breaking point and
then it ends up turning
inward to recognize the well of honey
that is
under the rock just like the parable of
the prodigal son
so simultaneously there is something
that is being done this is the god
self-realization portion when the
individual melts into the oneness you
hear about this a lot on people's
spiritual journeys when they talk about
oh i'm one with everything
they talk about that unity or cosmic
consciousness
from a science perspective they say
we're all made of stardust
from a planetary perspective they
recognize that
we are one of 10 million species on the
planet
they recognize that they are one of
eight billion
humans on the planet that are all like
cells in a super organism
so there's many scientific people that
are even starting to understand that
they can't even take
a breath of air which they take 20 000
times a day
without summoning the phytoplankton
and trees that are undergoing
photosynthesis to give them that o2 to
inhale
so even the people that are being like
ah everything's interconnected
it's still an egoic consciousness that
is saying those things but it's
beginning to break into
the melting into the oneness and so this
is basically the
phase of the spiritual journey
which is the most important thing the
most important thing is
your spiritual journey you're seeking
yourself
god realization which is then actually
going to lead even further to the
recognition that
even that is in itself also
a dream
so the progress for people
to go from drop to ocean
is huge okay so it's the first one drop
becomes ocean
so that's already beginning to pierce
the veil a little bit
so you're no longer as much this egoic
contracted separate entity
but your sugar cube has began to
dissolve into
the oceanic infinitude
now when you fully dissolve the
ego you recognize more and more that you
are the ocean that is experiencing the
waves
another another analogy that we've been
using a lot on the program is you are
this blank paper
that is the observer that is the witness
that we all share
that is the i am slash self
that is the pupil the eye of god or the
self that we all
share so eight billion in a
sense set of eyes of one
god of the one source
of the one infinite creator and that
we recognize the coloration aka the
words
so meaning the ocean which is the blank
paper
recognizes the waves which is the words
on the paper so now
you've in a sense you've created the
juxtaposition for yourself
where you recognize more and more that
oh i am this blank
paper this oceanic-ness that is
experiencing this coloration
these waves and the waves are your
emotions
thoughts feelings objects beliefs
experiences perceptions sensations
taste touch feel sense
smell
and so we recognize that those are just
waves of coloration
onto the i am self ocean
and we begin more and more over time
surfing on the crest
in the eternal now in that presence
simply this
now this happening
now and we understand more and more that
we're not affiliating ourselves as much
with
the the coloration
in the sense of wanting it to be
different having craving
or having a version but rather we are
just the experiencer
of the wave now typically
this process of becoming more and more
in tune with riding on the crest and
recognizing that we are the ocean
experiencing the waves
usually leads us to something like
recognizing the tantric path where we
weave
our realizations into the social fabric
or
otherwise known as sahaja samadhi
now that's a very natural effortless
action wu wei
experience that ends up channeling
through you
because as you recognize that our being
is shared
even though we're going to unpack here
that it's a dream or an illusion
at the same time you still channel the
absolute highest
morality effortlessly out
in that tantric path sahaja samadhi
and then we realize that
even above the i am or the self
is the complete
declination you decline the fact that
you are
even an observer or a witness
and you go even further
into the realization that
even that which appears
to be the observer of the
experiences even that which appears to
be the ocean
experiencing the coloration of the waves
in itself is an illusion in itself
is a dream
and that's what these are that's what
the non-dual teaching
is this is already perfect this is
already
whole this is already indescribable
perfection it is already
unconditionally free and unconditionally
loving
it remains for you to recognize that it
is
but that is our true nature that is the
true nature of non-duality
just formlessness absolute formlessness
that is agentless and that is
attributeless
and perfect that is
in an illusion in a dreamlike way
being expressed as these
realities where there is an exploration
these are
some of the best words that we've been
able to identify so far it's an
exploration it's a play
and even then there is no meaning to it
there's no meaning to it
as much as you want to say that it's
exploring
infinity as a meaning that still
has no meaning
meaning would mean that there is an end
goal that we must finish
exploring infinity
there is no end goal it just
is it just
is this
simply appearing it's just this
and so yes we recognize even the witness
even the experiences are a dream we
recognize that we shift from
something as in we shift from ah this is
all
form i am going to egoic separate entity
in some random world of form
we shift from that to literally nothing
no thing so we recognize
formlessness we recognize agentlessness
we recognize our own illusion of our
own meanness
even that that one is so hard for the
ego to let go of
and it's even hard for the i am slash
self to let go of because we want so
badly for there to be meaning we want so
badly for there to be purpose we want so
badly for
there to be some sort of an agent that
is experiencing
something that has a meaning that has
purpose but there is none of that
there's no agent there's no experiencing
there's no meaning there's no purpose
now
true simultaneity this does not mean
to
undergo a process after
having these pointed out to you where
there's a complete lethargy and apathy
that's not the tantric path that's not
the middle way
that's not sahaja samadhi the non-dual
tradition
is that you make these profound
realizations
of the illusion of the dream
yet you have a childlike
peace a child like bliss an
awe a wonder as you do your daily
activities
you stay in the eternal present
you stay in the absolute formlessness
as you do your daily activities when
somebody says
atlas that they need you to bring the
microphone to them
at 3 pm so they give you a name they
give you a form
and they give you a time you respond
properly now if you want to play a
little bit and say that there is no
atlas
there is no microphone and time does not
exist
you can definitely play like that and
it's hilarious to play like that
because then you can have other people
slowly
recognize more and more that ah because
they may have
not recognized that they may have
literally just been a contracted egoic
separate entity
in a random physical world
so again the intention is simply to
pierce the veil
in the dream so
again in true simultaneity there is both
absolutely
infinite indescribable perfection
already
unconditionally free yet at the same
time
there is a seeking impulse and that's to
discover the diamond necklace that is
already around your neck
but that recognition has a lot to do
with these steps in a sense in terms of
the drop
that melts into the ocean
and also the and that's like the egoic
contracted entity that melts into the
oceanic
infinitude which then recognizes itself
as the
observer or the witness or the i am or
the self
that is experiencing the waves
or if you want to use the analogy of the
sky you are the sky experiencing the
clouds
or you are the paper experiencing the
words or you are the screen
experiencing the images
and that even there we ride the crest
more
and more in the now better and better
and we do that tantric path of sahaja
samadhi of weaving
our enlightened realizations into the
social fabric and yet
even then we come to the realization
that
even the i am even the self even the
witness even the observer itself
is an illusion is a dream
the experiences themselves are a dream
they are an illusion they are
appearances
and that is really when you
hit the peak that's when you hit the
peak of the mountaintop
so if you want to think about it it's
like the ego and we're working on making
visuals
for this right now the ego is at the
base the sea level
of the mountain and then the paths
are the process of seeking
finding is the process of reaching the
snow
at the top which is in many ways
piercing the veil to that i
am or that self that we were talking
about here where you
realize you're the ocean experiencing
the waves and then the absolute pinnacle
itself is the recognition that there are
no ocean there is no ocean there is no
waves
there is no ocean there are no waves
and true simultaneity is your ability to
navigate all of that
so you can navigate the state where
there is no ocean there's no waves
not a problem you can also navigate the
state
of when you're you know checking out at
the grocery store and you're being asked
a question
you know you don't just say oh this is
all an illusion this is all a dream
you don't know you you properly check
out at the grocery store and whatnot
that's what true simultaneity is
and that's what piercing the veil
in the dream is use this oceanic analogy
i hope it brought you value again the
drop becomes the ocean
the ocean experiences the waves and then
there
are no waves and there is no ocean
great let me know in the comments where
you're at
in your journey would love to hear from
you and
like the video subscribe if you haven't
share the video with people that you
think would find this valuable
it's already indescribably perfect
it is already whole it is already
completely
unconditionally free and loving
that is the essence
it's agentless
it's attributeless
it's metaphysical zero
childlike wonder bliss
peace play
aww
thank you
c